مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في مجزره من قناه
الجزيره افادت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
باستشهاد شاب برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي شمال الخليل جهه قالت هيئه تبث
الاسرائيليه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي اطلق
النار على فلسطينيا اثناء محاولته اطلاقا
نيران باتجاه قوه عسكريه في المنطقه
وطالبت 99 دوله اسرائيل بالتراجع عن
الاجراءات العقبيه ضد الفلسطينيين من جهته
قال وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي من البيانات
الدوليه لا معنى لها اكد ان اسرائيل تلتزم
بامنها قبل اي شيء
افادت وصل الام الاسرائيليه وامريكيه انا
وفدا من الكونجرس الامريكي طلب من
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين عدم اشتراك اي
ممثلين عن حزبي وزيري الامن القومي اتمار
بني كثير والماليه
بتسلائي خلال الاجتماعات الوافدين في
اسرائيل
تتواصل المعارك في شرق اوكرانيا الاستيماء
على جبهه بخموت التي تنفيذ محاصرتها من
قبل الجانب الروسي وقد بثت قياده العمليات
الاوكرانيه صورا تظهر استهدافا المدفعيه
الاوكرانيا مجموعه
اخرى
باسم عمليات المنطقه الشرقيه الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الرئيسيه لا توسيطر فعليا على
كامل مدينه السويداء
اكدت رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه وارسلها
فوندر لاين استمرار دعم اوكرانيا وتوعدت
بعدم افلاط روسيا من العقاب من الجهاته حث
الرئيس البولندي اوروبا على تسريع امداد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات اما رئيس مقدونيا
الشماليه فقال للجزيره الى الفشل في
التصدي لنظام بوتن يعني ان اوكرانيا لن
تكون اخر دوله تحاول موسكو احتلالها في
المقابل قالت الخارجيه الروسيه الى موسكو
سات ترد بالشكل والتوقيت المناسب على اي
اعمال غير وديه ضدها من قبل الدول الغربيه
قال الوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان تقديم
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا هو قرار
السياديون لكل بلد اضافر يمكن من الهندسه
من تزويده اوكرانيا بالسلاح هو الوصول الى
وضع يسهل على الطرفين لان الخراطه
المفاوضات
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
ان بلاده سوفت الشروط التي تضمنها اتفاق
التفاهم من موقع العمل ماضي مع تركيا اكد
هذا في تصريح الجزيره ان الكره الان في
ملعب انقره البديل في اجراءات التصديقي
على عضويه السويد في النيته حسب تعبير
وزير الخارج
للتزامي بتعهدات في مكافحه التنظيمات التي
تعتبرها انقره ارهابيه وقال ان الخيار
الان بيدي السكن
[موسيقى]